lancelin should be fully healed from his
il stint as you can see his sixth start
of the year he's three and one he's been
brilliant with a 152.
he's got good control he is a power
pitcher and right-handers left-handers
doesn't matter
so that's what he used last time out the
four seamer at 43 of them the cutter at
30. so basically
he's a fastball pitcher in fact they're
all fast balls right there
so luisa rise the left-handed hitting
second baseman will lead it off
and arise hits it in the air until left
center field
this is andrew vaughn against the wind
very smooth on the back end of it one
gone
here's donaldson three and two right
there
strike three donaldson sent away two
gone
and takes a sinker for a strike he's
gone two away
polanco switch hitter swinging a mess he
struck him out
on a cutter and the twins go one two
three
nato with a good track record against
the white sox since putting on a twins
uniform
first pitch that tim drills to left
field
and welcome to the ballpark bring him
home one nothing
white sox lead one to nothing
that's what we're mentioning about the
offense
yeah they're not struggling
that was one and done for tim anderson
and he has been somebody in that
lead-off spot in the past
very familiar with sitting on the first
pitch
tim anderson now on an eight-game hit
streak
he's five for 10 in the series see how
kyle garlick fares
lancelin hasn't hit against
right-handers an awful lot has been
very good against left-handed pitching
struck him out high fastball
garlic gets smoked and that's five
strikeouts for lance lim
who really has exceptional stuff right
now
last two starts seven and two thirds
eleven strikeouts you
can't mince words about that and just
one base runner on the catcher's
interference
ground ball sharply hit to the shortstop
gloved by anderson
low throw and land couldn't handle it
and arise
is safe that could be an error on lamb i
think he just
was deceived he thought that would be in
the dirt and he was getting ready for a
pick
and it just kept coming to him and then
handcuffed him so he just misread it
you know he hasn't played a whole lot of
first base this year should have been a
routine 6-3
inning ender instead he's got to face
josh donaldson
popped him up shallow center racing in
is billy hamilton he's got the
sunglasses on he makes the catch he'll
lead off the bottom of the third
so lynn works around the two-out error
here comes jake lamb struck out in the
first
fly ball well hit right center field it
is
gone a home run he just got it over the
eight
foot high wall a two-strike home run
for jake lamb
first as a white sox and it's two
nothing
what a beautiful short compact powerful
swing
on a sinker down i mean that is throwing
some top hand on a pitch
that was pretty darn tough to lift the
twins have a
runner in scoring position first hit
kepler coming into the ball game move
for two
ground ball right to lynn off his hand
picks it up
throws low and lamb can't catch it
here comes larnick he'll score so
there'll be an error i believe charged
to lance lynn
that shook up lance there for a little
bit he pounced to it then
fired another fastball to first base
that lamb could not catch and then it
kicked away from lamb and lardic heads
up
saw the whole ploy and score without a
throw i want to get too much sun
heard of cars with bucket seats but well
cooler heads prevail
oh that's the winner error on the
pitcher
allowing the twins to get their first
run base is loaded and here's garland
swinging a high fly ball well hit left
center
hamilton at the wall he leaps he makes a
catch
billy hamilton with a great grab
and the inning is over it was really
good
and pretty much the game could have been
on the line as he goes back
and times it perfectly faces loaded two
out
and a 3-2 from lynn
lynn is excited as he gets out of this
inning
by striking out garber looking nine
strikeouts runners at second and third
with one out
white sox lead two to one the batter is
andrew vaughn
and that's lined to left field andrew
comes through in a stop sign at third
sox will get one and take that it is
three
to one first pitch swing by andrew
vaughn
well that's called preparation
as he walked up there with the
information from the bench saying hey
this guy's going to try and get ahead of
you with the heater
you're ready to go and it was a heater
and he turned on it
with authority so it's two walks
here for garrett two on for cruz big leg
kick
and he struck him out there's the slider
that's the slider that was waiting that
entire at-bat to strike out cruz and
he finally decided to throw it
now lefty lefty it's larnick call
strike three slider freezes larnick
thank you ethan katz stretch time
and now in what really is quite a test
for jose ruiz he comes on for the 14th
time
era of one and a quarter this becomes
the first high leverage situation for
him of the year he's been throwing it so
exceptionally well
that he earned this particular spot but
this is like
maybe how a parent would test one of
their kids about
doing something can i trust you with the
car this time if i
leave and i'm gone for more than 10
minutes i mean can i trust you
kepler strikeout reached down in error
and then
fouled out to the catcher line drive
into right field deep that ball's back
and that ball's gone a home run so
kepler
a line drive homer to right his eighth
career homer at guaranteed right field
his third this season and it's now a
one-run
game 3-2 chicago as liam hendricks
come with two on one out second straight
day for lamb to be out there
trying to save the ball game horiz hits
it well into left center field hamilton
again speeds over
and rescues the ball game this one
probably scores two if it gets by
it doesn't get by what a play by billy
hamilton
one more out to get by in the very tough
josh donaldson
that was a high fastball that's popped
up
on the infield tim makes a call leaning
ted makes the catch going down to the
ground
high anxiety gymnastics
to rescue the lead from
tim anderson so you're mean with an
opportunity
to come off the bench and get a big hit
mercedes saw it beautifully
up the gap in left center this lead will
grow
abreu scores and a pinch hit rbi
dagger for mercedes and a 4-2 lead
pull shift against the lefty
righty hendricks fires strike three
the white sox have swept the twins
they are six and oh into this 13-game
stretch